et on commence cette page loisir avec
les nuits des forêts à partir de demain
et jusqu'au 18 juin l'événement se
déroule partout en France dans les
Yvelines plusieurs activités sont
proposées pour en parler avec nous Clara
enguenau la co-fondatrice des nuits des
forêts et Brigitte teinturier la
responsable commerciale et marketing de
l'Espace Rambouillet Clara enguenau
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé
d'où est venu cette idée de créer les
nuits des forêts donc vu cette idée
alors c'est un festival qu'on a imaginé
en fait pendant le premier confinement
donc on va dire que au début elle est
venue surtout d'un besoin de prendre
l'air et de d'aller en pleine nature
et aussi on avait à coeur de de créer un
temps pour aller à la rencontre de de
personnes qui connaissent bien les
forêts soit parce qu'il étudient des
scientifiques des chercheurs ou parce
qu'ils l'entretiennent comme des
gestionnaires forestiers par exemple ou
des propriétaires
et le tout on voulait le faire quand
même dans un esprit festif pour en faire
quand même un temps convivial et comme
je disais on était en plein confinement
donc il y avait une volonté aussi de
partager des moments forts et c'est
comme ça qu'on a eu l'idée d'un festival
et qui a du coup aussi toute une
dimension artistique et ludique et pas
seulement pédagogique et alors pourquoi
le faire la nuit alors c'est je précise
que c'est le jour et la nuit mais c'est
vrai que la spécificité du festival et
que on a beaucoup d'événements qui
durent pendant la nuit
l'idée c'était
d'inviter à aller découvrir la forêt de
manière originale on a l'habitude
d'aller en forêt pour les champignons le
VTT quelques pique-nique l'escalade mais
là on voulait aussi inviter à sortir un
peu de sa zone de confort et puis aussi
à la nuit qui tombe on a toute la faune
qui se réveille donc pour observation
écoute des oiseaux
d'autres animaux c'est très propice
voilà après c'était la nuit aussi
l'univers
fantastique voilà onirique derrière la
forêt qu'on voulait mettre à l'honneur à
travers ce titre et alors l'Espace
Rambouillet participe à cet événement
Brigitte teinturier quels sont les
activités que vous allez proposer cette
année alors nous on a une soirée qui se
déroule en plusieurs temps
justement parce que on va commencer
entre chien et loups au moment où il
fait encore jour mais
justement les nocturnes ne sont pas
encore sorties donc on va démarrer par
une petite balade forestière pour venir
découvrir la forêt et ses secrets
on va en livrer quelques-uns en tout cas
on espère surprendre un petit peu nos
invités
on a nous au niveau du parc un espace
qu'on appelle la forêt sauvage qui se
prête particulièrement bien puisque
dessus on a des animaux qui sont en
semi-liberté et donc on va
faire une petite balade au sein de ces
parcelles là arriver à la mars
Saint-Rémy qui est un lieu vraiment très
atypique du parc pour ensuite profiter
en fait d'un vol de nos rapaces puisque
l'espace a aussi la forêt des aigles une
volière avec des rapaces que l'on
présente en vol et qui seront
accompagnés justement sur cette partie
artistique d'une joueuse de harpe
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui va nous
on a vraiment conçu une approche très
grand public et cette soirée ensuite
nous ramène à nouveau au niveau de de la
forêt et là on va avoir un spectacle
vivant ou en fait on va aborder en fait
le sujet des arthropodes qui sont les
petits insectes les pollinisateurs qui
sont essentiels à l'écosystème de la
forêt donc
le concept a été travaillé sur une base
pour être accessible à notre public qui
est un public familial
et qui en même temps un moyen
d'auto-frère une découverte justement
originale et unique de ce lieu qui est
l'Espace Rambouillet oui si je comprends
bien l'objectif c'est de faire connaître
la faune et la flore dans les forêts qui
sont proches de chez nous finalement oui
et d'évoquer en fait ce qu'est la forêt
en soi
par rapport à ces enjeux historiques et
c'est là où on rejoint vraiment le
souhait des nuits des forêts de d'offrir
justement une information variée et
divers sur les écosystèmes que rendent
la forêt aujourd'hui donc on a un
partenaire qui est FIBOIS qui sera
présent aussi sur sur l'espace et dont
la vocation justement est de promouvoir
tous les métiers autour du bois et alors
plus largement Clara engono quel est le
programme dans les Yvelines de ces nuits
des forêts
alors donc les événements sont
essentiellement sur les deux weekends à
venir dans les Yvelines et donc ce
week-end c'est beaucoup sur le massif de
Rambouillet il y a l'ONF l'Office
National des Forêts organise une sortie
nocturne un spectacle de contes par une
compagnie qui s'appelle la Cour des
comptes mais compte histoire pas les
contraintes il y a aussi un très beau
concert de violoncelle en forêt de Santa
Pauline
c'est une violence qui s'appelle Olivia
gay qui a un qui porte un projet mais à
titre citoyen pour faire découvrir le
répertoire de musique classique et ses
liens avec la nature et donc voilà pour
pour promouvoir aussi la beauté des
forêts et comme source d'inspiration
donc ça c'est le premier week-end et le
second il y aura encore beaucoup de
choses côté Saint-Germain-en-Laye aussi
il y aura des événements forêt des
portables départementales de ronqueux
une belle sortie par le organisé par le
département des Yvelines pour découvrir
justement les chauves-souris qui sont
des habitants en nocturne et de la forêt
voilà
on découvre donc la faune et la flore
mais aussi il y a des rendez-vous avec
des artistes des rendez-vous artistiques
en plein milieu de la forêt c'est ça
exactement qu'on essaye de faire
toujours la manière la plus légère
possible
l'idée on est quand même toujours sur
des petites jauges sur des interventions
très légères des artistes pour
évidemment aussi respecter le milieu
pour être en cohérence aussi avec les
nouvelles et alors comment faire pour
attirer les plus urbains ceux qui sont
peut-être moins attirés par la forêt
pour voilà les faire venir assez nuit
des forêts
alors si c'est bien chaud ils peuvent
avoir envie de venir se rafraîchir non
c'est vrai que c'est une question il y
avait quand même la problématique des
transports en Île-de-France en tout cas
on sait alors il y a des espaces
naturels notre forestiers est connecté
mais c'est pas toujours bien donc nous
on essaye d'encourager aussi la
communication sur vous pouvez venir
aussi avec une ligne de RER de TER de
Transilien
et puis ensuite je pense que les formats
atypiques
proposés comme comme ce soit l'Espace
Rambouillet et d'autres aident aussi à
attirer une population plus urbaine et
d'avoir ce mélange des genres
différents publics aussi alors le mot de
la fin Brigitte teinturier pourquoi la
forêt c'est important pour vous parce
qu'il est essentiel à notre vie on va
reparler ce sont les poumons de la terre
clairement et puis aujourd'hui bien si
on veut sortir des énergies carbone bien
évidemment ça passe aussi par le
maintien de cette forêt et sa gestion au
quotidien qui est vraiment essentielle
et c'est là où l'ONF entre autres et
aussi les propriétaires privés sont
essentiels pour une gestion raisonnée de
la forêt qui intervient pour aujourd'hui
de nombreux systèmes écosystèmes
des services pour pour la population
dans sa globalité et pour vous que Lara
Haguenau pourquoi c'est important la
forêt en quelques mots
ce sont des lieux essentiels à notre
bien-être et presque à notre survie j'ai
envie de dire donc c'est vraiment des
lieux qu'il faut bien connaître qu'il
faut apprendre à protéger mais il faut
aussi apprendre à bien vivre avec elle
et de leur ressources donc c'est
important de d'y aller et bien merci à
vous deux Clara anconnu et Brigitte
teinturier d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors dans les Yvelines les
forêts couvrent plus de 68 000 hectares
soit environ 30% de la surface du
département c'est l'un des départements
les plus boisés d'Île-de-France
d'ailleurs donc il y a plusieurs
rendez-vous vous les voyez s'afficher
sur votre écran vous retrouverez tout le
programme sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran